[Music]
i did i talk about this the other day i
went to that the blippi show did i tell
you about this no all right so
so do you know who blippi is have you
ever heard of blippi i don't know what
that is no all right so like remember
like back there we had barney or like
you know uh like pee wee herman or
whatever he's like it's like it's a dude
so he kind of looks like peter herman or
whatever but he's more like a barney or
you know um sesame street style show so
basically there's a guy who went on
youtube created this brand called blippi
and he um
he's entertaining so he'd be like oh and
by the way the funny thing that he does
is there's no like set he just goes into
like um hey we're at the aquarium but
they just go in like after 9 p.m it's
like closed down and so it's just they
have it all to themselves like hey we're
here in las vegas at this rock climbing
studio and so he just uses that to film
his thing but he gives it a shout out at
the beginning of the video the video
gets like 40 million views so it's like
uh well you know
it's worth it to let these guys film
there and he just like goes around he'll
basically just play with toys he'll be
like i'm at an abandoned chuck e cheese
and he'll go play with a bunch of toys
and there's like music and whatever
overlaid and it's the same guy i'm
looking at him now it's the same guy
every single time it is except for as he
blew up and got famous then they
switched him out with just a stunt
double for a bit and so like that guy's
like a substitute teacher sometimes and
then sometimes when flippy comes back uh
but like the main guy is the main guy he
wears his outfits like this blue outfit
with his orange glasses he like always
looks the same
so anyways my daughter loved blippi we
used to watch a ton of bloopy and all of
a sudden we see this ad that says um
blippi like the live show is coming to
oakland
and so we were like oh and so
instantly my wife buys tickets for for
all of us in the family we go to this
thing last weekend
and it's it's at the same place you did
hustle con so it's at the paramount
theater
and
it is packed like you know hustle khan
was like you know
sold out ish this was like sold out sold
out like all the even the back shitty
seat is like sold out
and it's full of parents and their kids
and then there's this like this they
basically just created like a little
play like a little mini musical one hour
because kids don't have that long of an
attention span and it's just kind of
like music and like you know lights and
colors and he's
oh dinosaurs oh rocks oh how much should
it cost
so every ticket i want to say was that
venue's seats maybe like 60 bucks a seat
something like that so that's been used
seats between 2 500 and 3 000 i believe
yeah so i think there was 2 000 there
um
and i believe the tickets were something
like
um
something like 50 60 70 bucks something
like that so we're in like 120 000 and
he played four shows in a row um that
weekend and then he went to the next
city so it was our like no he had done
eight shows or he was doing something
like that so it was like some crazy like
thing where i was like oh wow this
weekend they made whatever 800 grand
um and yeah the tickets tickets
basically range from like you know 60
bucks to 90 bucks
and um and the place is lit by the way
so like you know he comes on stage kids
go crazy he's like
you know he'd be like you know what does
the bubble do and everyone's like pop
and he's like when i say pop can you say
pop and like so it's like not like a
quiet show like because kids are loud
anyways so some kids are just not paying
attention have to like my daughter
during intermission was like i want to
watch blippi on youtube and so we like
had to open up youtube on our phone and
give it to her during intermission
because she couldn't like go five
minutes without stimulation and so it's
and then they have like the merch and
the like the concessions they have like
all that right so it's like pretty
dope actually and i was like wow this is
kind of genius they just took youtube ip
and this is this guy who was there was
not blippi the guy on stage was just
some
you know theater kid who like didn't
make it you know and so he's like all
right plan b i'll be blippi
and um and so it was like
they took the ip but they made their own
show out of it and so i started looking
into this and there's a company that
does this called vstar entertainment
awesome so v-star what they do is they
go license these kids brands and then
they put on kids broadway basically and
they tour around the country awesome and
so and blippi is just a guy with a
guitar right or were there more
tournaments no guitar he's just just him
he just watched so were there any
instruments or was it just like a
soundtrack just soundtrack and like
lights and like uh stage props so wow so
he he always kind of like
like you know if they came out as sharks
like a bunch of like little backup
dancers came out as sharks and then they
whatever like that's an awesome mini
theater show right
and so
v star entertainment they do another
brand that you've probably heard of call
or you may have heard of called paw
patrol it's basically another kids
cartoon so guess how much
this is my like kind of triangulation
guess how much they sold in paw patrol
tickets last year just take it take a
guess
20 20 mil 40 million dollars and 40
million dollars in event tickets and
event tickets for and that's just the
tickets not the murder that was just
last year and 22. uh i don't know it's
like this is like the just before covet
numbers so like
2019 2020 something like that wow so
they got bought by cirque du soleil
so first so the back story is some guy
decides oh you know what like he's
watching sesame street he's like sesame
street should do a live show
and he goes and he basically raises 500
grand from this guy he mortgages his
house he gets an extra 25 grand out of
his home equity so he's got 525 thousand
dollars he goes and he gets the license
to sesame street he started with the
sesame street show and then muppets and
like he you know did but that must have
been years ago this was in like 1980
something like that yeah
and then
um this other guy was doing it they
merged and that whole thing gets bought
by cirque du soleil last year is it
cirque du soleil by the way like guess
how much cirque du soleil revenue was
have you ever written a cirque show no
i've not but i do know that the guy who
started it uh is a canadian guy he's a
billionaire i read dan blizzarian's book
and they talk about that guy a lot i
think he's like i mean he started a
circus so he's like liberty or whatever
yeah he's really eccentric and wild and
everything so it made him a billionaire
how much revenue does it make um ben
have you been to a cirque du soleil show
cirque du soleil did a billion does a
billion dollars a year in revenue which
is insane
ten percent a five or ten percent of all
las vegas tourists
go to a circ show when they're in town
is that what
what's that cirque is that the is that
they have like ten shows right it'll be
like they have oh and then they have
zoomanity they have like whatever and
the beatles yeah i know all about it and
i'm i'm into it and it's publicly traded
or at least it was before it was
acquired by private equity right right
private equity owns it now and um
and it's a pretty badass business the
idea was do a circus but no animals so
it was like only human performers and to
do that they did like crazy acrobats and
like great costumes it's basically its
own genre at this point though right and
so he built that thing into a real
juggernaut and so cirque then bought
blue man group and v star entertainment
and so they got blue man which is like
an ad
what they had said was like we do 10
million in ticket sales a year for
cirque du soleil blue man adds another 2
million and then um and then v star adds
another two million but they're all like
different ticket prices but like
they do 14 million in tickets uh sold
per year and so this this like live
entertainment thing really has caught my
attention because
i think as the world moves more and more
digital
that they're like the demand for like
these one-off experiences like hey let's
get out of the house and go do something
i think it's just gonna keep going up
music festivals that's a winner and then
there's like uh i think plays and
musicals are gonna be a winner i think
they're going to be bigger than they
were before even though the world news
digital and in fact because the world
moves digital what do you think about
all this i 100 agree and so earlier
today i sent you a notion doc of some of
my notes on i'm interested in peer
businesses which is basically like you
pay money and you're part of a club and
you meet up with them and i i can't talk
too much about what the names of the
companies were but they were doing like
uh one of them does 100 million a year
in profit and it's basically two or
three meetups a year and there's
executives paying 50 000 a year to be
part of them and i think actually these
are going to completely boom i think
conferences right now are interesting
but those are really hard this actually
seems way easier to pull off um
all types of meetups airbnbs i'm 100 on
board that i think that in person is is
the move
yeah i and i think that so then i
started thinking like what are the other
opportunities and so i think a you could
just like go compete with these guys on
like either the same brands or another
brand so like what they did was
the v star guy took tv ip turned it into
a live show the what the flipping guy is
doing is taking youtube ip and turning
it into a live show and i think you
could just even do this for more so like
i think you could even do like
we've talked about religion which is the
greatest free ip in the world so i think
somebody could do this for religion
which would make a extremely kid
friendly in fact kid-focused
like christianity show basically i think
you could do this for dinosaurs or
science as a generic genre because like
if kids love trucks and dinosaurs or
whatever and you could just basically
create the like
the the show you know day with dinosaurs
or something like that and it once you
get like if you have a certain level of
quality
moms will spread this and they will talk
about it and they will like in their
mommy groups they will help you sell
these tickets
and um
and i just feel like there's a like it's
not that hard like you build one show
and then you sell that one show a
thousand times right like the show goes
on tour mamma mia has made like i don't
know some stupid amount of money just
being the same show on tour with
replacing the the low cost action yeah
anytime i'm trying while we're talking
i'm trying to find the numbers so we
used to so we did events but we would do
like these this thing called hustle con
which was like our big one where like
thousands of people would come but then
we do this thing called 2x and 2x was
basically from like 7 p.m to like 10 p.m
and it was basically we got 15 or 10
women
all who were in tech and business not
that many of them were like well known
but they would have 10 minutes to like
tell a story and we would charge like 25
but then we would get tens of thousands
of dollars in sponsors but we got to the
point where we could pull this off like
kind of like almost weekly in other
cities and when we started doing this
the hustle wasn't that popular but we
were making like i think like 30 grand a
night when we were doing it
and we had one employee running it right
and
she would use a team of contractors and
then we wouldn't supply anything like i
think we had free wine but i don't know
i don't even think it was free i like we
wouldn't supply anything but then we
have corporate sponsors and we crushed
it and in my head i'm like i can always
fall back on this to make a living
because it was so much easier than
people thought right
yeah that's pretty good for a tech bro
um a tech bro business like all of us
you you you were running one of the best
like women's entrepreneurship events
yeah because you got labeled wrong dude
yeah they're i'm like an onion man
there's layers so but basically like we
used to do this thing called pizza and
40s where we would do a meet-up and i
would interview someone and they would
drink a 40-ounce and when the 40-ounce
beer was done the talk was done but then
like women were like this is like
there's all dudes here and so we created
like a like a wine version and that had
like way better it was like called like
cheese and wine i don't even remember
but that had way better engagement and
so we're like oh like let's pursue this
vein like this there's clearly an
opportunity here until we created 2x
which uh comes it's like 2x chromosomes
which i thought was clever i stole it
from reddit uh but anyway we would do i
think we did 10 or 12
uh in one year and every single time it
was like 20 and 30 grand and the cost
the cost was nothing the cost was
renting the venue which cost like three
thousand dollars and we would make like
20 grand and you also you had readers in
every city right so that's how you sold
the tickets is that yeah yeah but we
weren't basically the speakers sold the
tickets the reason why we had 15
speakers was was i was like i bet each
15 will get 25 people to come plus
our
like a little bit of our engine like
this is easy and you weren't making the
money off the tickets you're making
enough sponsors really anyway the
tickets the the business model was the
tickets paid for the event and then the
conference was all or the sponsors were
all the profit but when it's there's two
things going on one like women so
whenever you have like an underserved
community like sponsors definitely are
willing to pay more and two it was like
a b to b component so it wasn't kid's
component which i think would alter the
economics but my point of it is that i
think that it was far easier than people
thought and it was way more rudimentary
and raw than people thought and it
worked we just used splash that i think
if you google like 2x the hustle you'll
like see like the splash that is
basically eventbrite it was nothing
special
and it freaking worked
[Music]
you